the bite administration has opened
america's borders to the world and
pretty much no one is doing anything
about it as our democracy evaporates and
our nation changes forever but there are
a few state governors who are doing
something to protect their citizens from
the effect of mass illegal immigration
and no one's doing more than the
governor of florida ron desantis
desantis just announced new proposals to
stop the flow of criminal migrants into
a state here are some of them
we have a responsibility to stand up for
the rule of law we have a responsibility
to stand up for the constitution and we
have a responsibility to stand up
against an administration that has just
decided they don't want to have a secure
border you know you don't get to make
that decision the laws of our country
require us to enforce the law and that's
what needs to be done
well exactly you don't get to make that
decision for the executive you don't
make laws
you have to abide by them governor
desantis is abiding by federal law in
the state of florida he joins us tonight
governor thanks so much for coming on i
know you're a detailed man
um with the one thing we almost never
get from politicians so if you could
explain to the audience what exactly
you're doing in the state to protect
your citizens
sure tucker for one any of these
contractors that are facilitating binds
illegal policies by bringing people into
florida oftentimes flying in at two
o'clock in the morning with no notice to
the state anyone who's doing that
forfeits the ability to have contracts
with state and local government in the
state of florida and they're going to be
responsible for providing restitution to
the state of florida for every single
person that they bring because when they
dump somebody
a lot of costs end up being borne by the
state in the future whether that's
education health care whether that's the
criminal justice system unfortunately we
had somebody brought from biden that
murdered somebody in jacksonville just a
few weeks ago
and so we're very concerned about doing
that and we want to basically say this
is not the right decision to be making
to be facilitating which is basically an
illegal human smuggling operation we're
also saying to some of the institutions
in florida like non-profits we're not
going to be giving license to folks
who are actively helping biden do this
and so
we want people focusing on our own
citizens a lot of people do a lot of
great work we've got a lot of people in
our state that need help
and we can't just have people who are
from foreign countries displacing the
needs of our own people
well exactly and it is a massive
federally sponsored human smuggling
operation and it's illegal what kind of
so you're taking concrete steps that
will enrage the white house do you
anticipate some kind of legal conflict
with them
well we're already in legal conflict
with them we have a lawsuit against them
i will say uh they have already switched
from what they had been doing as a
result of our lawsuit they had been
giving people a notice to report you
come illegally they give you a sheet of
paper they say hey call us and schedule
a hearing sometime with no consequences
well obviously that is toothless they
now have shifted to doing what's called
the notice to appear once somebody
doesn't appear then they are deportable
without any additional process not only
biden would deport them but perhaps when
we have a change of administration you
would then be able to return these folks
back so we are locked in litigation
there i have no doubt that they'll try
to do something to trip us up but here's
the deal tucker
yes the federal government's got a lot
of authority on immigration but if
they're not doing their job if they're
forfeiting their responsibilities i just
don't think states should be in a
position where we're helpless and we
can't do anything so we anticipate
conflict but you can't just run away
from that and say you're not going to do
nothing the easiest thing for me to do
would just be to put out tweets put out
press releases you know complain about
it but i think people want to say let's
do something about it so i think we're
going to have some success i think
there'll obviously be some some uh
things we're going to have to overcome
in the courts or whatnot but that's fine
i'd rather be fighting
to get things done than to just forfeit
before we even play the game well that's
exactly right i think a lot of people
are starting to conclude who your
governor is may make a bigger difference
than who your president is and i hope
other governors will pay attention uh to
what you're doing ron desantis florida
thank you very much
thank you hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else